well
yeah i'm not sure i'd say that but i
suppose so yeah i mean i used to live
here
should we see if standby mine is there
yeah
okay so this is like this is the
relative camera
this is like kind of
the iconic building of oxford although
there's loads of buildings so obviously
this is like the biggest like there's
[__] loads of libraries here but this
is the biggest
this is quite a famous bridge
is it bridge of size
this is it by the way this is the eagle
department
[Music]
i want you to just do a couple quick
shots of the chapel and the dining hall
just tell me
[Music]
this is keyboard college this was my
college when i was oxford
you know what's funny about this uh
grass sin
no one is allowed on this grass unless
you're playing croquet
this is the dining hall
this is where the formal dinners take
place
before we go in i'll let you know a
couple of rules about formal dinners
one you have to wear a cape
number two
you're not allowed to leave
to go to the bathroom during the whole
dinner
and they sent out an email
saying we've heard people have been
leaving so it's not acceptable
uh
[Music]
hey
scenic's beautiful
this hammer is here
because um
before you start eating dinner you have
to wait for the big man to hit this
hammer on the billwood
[Music]
it's important
so this is where the uh
the economists have dinner after a long
hard day of algebra
[Music]
fancy
the paintings are all four made masters
[Music]
this one has a little bit of a distinct
style but you might not recognize that
unless you're kind of like familiar just
because it's red brick yeah um
after a tough day of algebra sometimes
the students will
write on the wall about how good they
are
[Music]
you